one hole is not to because it was to be
something like in the middle so this has
one oh right so how many knows it assess
one how do you guys these like the same
look if I put another hole in here
somebody try another hole putting this
hole to jump in one hole not one hook if
you jump in a straw jump in one strong
one ho riveting conversation this is
what happens when you legalize
recreational marijuana meet Deon who
believes a straw has two holes and turay
who is team one hole the only hole I
care about is glory and my wife's be
there debate went viral and divided the
nation because people love arguing hell
that's why the Winklevoss has invented
the facebook without debating stupid
stuff guys would never talk to each
other I've screamed at complete
strangers over whether it's gif or Jif
was the dress blue or an e his cereal
soup is Chipotle food should people pour
ketchup on top of their fries be
murdered would you rather have sex with
one adult size child or 100 child size
adults now these are questions but
there's nothing satisfying about winning
arguments in a world where every single
answer is in your pocket slowly giving
you testicular cancer hey Siri what do
you call someone who constantly pulls
out their phone to prove their right an
insufferable
friendless sack of thanks Siri
holes are the absence of space so
technically Dione and Tareq weren't
fighting about anything but the era
where everyone's opinion matters I felt
obligated to fly those two a-holes to
California where we avoided this
argument by banning straws for this
week's web rematch
[Applause]
welcome back to settle this the
number one urban debate show on Comedy
Central I'm your host d'etat let's meet
today's players he's a one-hole kind of
guy
say hey to terrain how are you I'm well
thank you for coming and it's daddy -
who the man behind the camera so where
are you from tre Columbus Ohio born and
raised are you from Columbus as well
now are you roommates close friends okay
Dan you were filming how long into that
argument did you decide wait I've got to
start recording this probably two
minutes
I thought I was over you're not trying I
tried to make him look stupid now were
you surprised that it got popular yeah I
was cuz like once the upload is started
like you retweets pretty fast overall
online who was deemed the winner
oh it's split down the middle it's weird
- cuz you're from Ohio which is a swing
state always on the fence on issues it's
like you're Hillary Clinton and you're
Donald Trump no I'm here weekly and
you're Donald Trump I want to be done
with changing your Donald Trump all
right has to be not on Dancing is this
the dumbest argument you've ever gotten
into I remember we had argue about his
buffalo sauce hot sauce yes it has to be
hot sauce buffalo sauce is ranch with
hot sauce in it so once you mix it it's
not ranches ranch hunts with buffalo
wings I think you're talking like a
chipotle aioli or something like that
it's dairy mixed with cayenne pepper
sauce which is hot sauce but if it's got
Cayenne in it then it's hot sauce now I
disagree
okay I have spent way too much time
getting to know you let's get right to
the speedball round the first debate
abortion
[Music]
abortions are baby murders yeah don't
let him talk to you like that
no managed to tell a woman what to do
with her body weight is a lunch wrap
more of a sandwich or a burrito is that
be a burrito is right it's a sandwich
sandwich shops so wraps not burritos
does the United States need
comprehensive gun control everybody has
the right to tote that pole guns are not
the answer we clearly need to do
something kids gang cue counterpoint is
Emma Stone hot is climate change real
sure it's real it's not your merciful
well I'll be dead before it's our
problem yep
[Applause]
if the n-word is in a song can white
people sing it this is unprecedented
[Applause]
we all know that sound means it's time
to put the settle to the metal for our
final issue how many holes does a straw
have a straw has two hoes straw I just
say my mother hos got a donut has one
but it's a straw like donut you sit
through one side and the juice comes
through the other side basically but all
the juice goes boom what if it's a straw
one straw and then just out the middle
another straw goes out just this way so
it's a why how many holes is that that
come off like a why yeah it's a hole
right there and it's a hole right there
it's too low so I'm gonna jump in this
also might be jumping out they jump in
this one they come out the bottom so why
do I got a question I've got a question
if there was a huge straw right here
here was a nice jump in the straw many
hoes did I jump in how many holes does a
t-shirt have we talk about each other
all we thought about was throwing it
jumping in
imagine a ground whole tunnel like this
and it goes like this growl can go on
this hole or this hole you're saying
that one hole is one hole - interest
what if over goes into the ground digs a
hole and comes out of the ground
yeah but now he goes through the same
first hole and then goes half the
distance this time and goes straight up
so that there's a second exit how many
holes are in the ground there's three
different hole thank you it's true Thank
You Sadie Thank You different in the
straw house nothing to do it there's
three that means if you take the middle
one out then there's two you're trying
to go through life from one two three
yeah exactly you're trying to go from
one to three is a ring one or two holes
a ring which one it's 100 rings one hole
if you've got a ring ring if Danny has
to be - it's an ancient sand eggsy you
could put your finger to different size
of one that's not true ancient my
buttholes a hole there's no exit right
that's why it's gold that's why it's one
hole
I agree with you on the ring but I don't
agree with you on the Gopher what
happens when you fold it in the middle
and then you look at it like that
so if you drill a hole in the wall how
many houses you killing wha what are the
straws those that you stir a coffee with
there's a seam down the middle of them
oh so people were still older one it's
so people will be going home it'd be
called peepholes it's one HO two O's one
hole
[Applause]
we need a black hole expert to settle
this please welcome Neil deGrasse Tyson
dude I'll have a straw but I have a
didgeridoo and it's got one hole through
it get over it
[Applause]
he just sell this here's your
world's smartest person of the week
t-shirt and your crown good night thanks
Neil he's a fan of this show how smart
could he possibly be